[Música]
bienvenidos a 5 minutos con en chile- al
menos 111 mujeres que se habían acogido
al programa de planificación familiar
que dispone el estado quedaron
embarazadas tras usar un anticonceptivo
defectuoso la situación se presenta
semanas después que diputadas de la
comisión de la mujer y equidad de género
presentarán un proyecto de ley que busca
despenalizar el aborto en ese país por
ello nos acompaña a javier a canales
aguilera directora ejecutiva de la
corporación miles chile gracias por
estar aquí con nosotros en francés 24
señora javier a muy buen día miles de
mujeres especialmente aquellas de bajos
recursos son las beneficiarias de este
programa de las píldoras anticonceptivas
que entrega el estado a pesar de que el
gobierno reconoció su error que medidas
legales pueden tomar estas personas
hola buenos días por acá nosotras hemos
estado trabajando en tres alternativas
principales una solicitar la
interrupción voluntaria del embarazo en
polar la interrupción montar el embarazo
en tres causales nosotros solamente
tenemos despenalizado tres causales una
de ellas riesgo de vida en este sentido
nosotros estamos trabajando en aquellas
mujeres que tienen una situación
psíquica bastante vulnerable y que esto
ha impactado fuertemente en sus vidas y
en sus proyectos de vida también una
indemnización de perjuicios en contra
del estado y en contra de laboratorio
estamos trabajando en esta en esta
demanda creando una comisión técnica de
profesionalidad 2 para poder representar
a estas mujeres y como tercera vía ya
presentábamos en el mes de diciembre y
ahora vamos presentar nuevamente en el
mes de febrero a final del mes de
febrero una acción urgente ante la
comisión a perdón ante la relatoría de
salud y mujeres de las naciones unidas y
adicionalmente ingresamos nuevamente
urgente ante la comisión interamericana
de derechos humanos
ahora javier a le pregunto cuál es la
gravedad de lo que está ocurriendo en
chile respecto a este tema y cuál es la
responsabilidad real del estado
acá hay una responsabilidad objetiva de
acuerdo a nuestra legislación vigente
por deficiencia en los medicamentos el
estado antes de poner en circulación los
medicamentos que compra debe primero
pasar por diversos exámenes de
estabilidad por el instituto de salud
pública ellos fallo estos medicamentos
se compraron en el mes de septiembre del
año 2019 y no puede estar mes de agosto
del año 2020 que se hizo en definitiva a
la alerta de que este anticonceptivo
eran defectuoso por qué es tan
importante y por qué es tan grave que
este anticonceptivo en particular haya
sido el defectuoso porque es el que se
distribuye gratuitamente a las mujeres
de escasos recursos en todo chile
alrededor del 60% de las mujeres en
chile consumen este anticonceptivo
ahora como hacen ustedes desde su
organización para poder ayudar a estas
mujeres afectadas nosotras nos dedicamos
la diferencia de promoción de los
derechos sexuales los derechos
reproductivos desde la tramitación de la
ley introducción bogotá del embarazo en
tres causales en este sentido somos
bastante conocida en el medio acá en en
chile por la fiscalización y la
promoción de estos derechos entonces una
vez que sale la ley está nosotros
pusimos a disposición nuestra área legal
a disposición nuestra área de salud
sexual y psicosocial para todas para
todas aquellas mujeres que se han visto
afectada y ella mediante correo
electrónico de distintas partes que
comunican con nosotras y nosotros le
asignamos una hora con una dupla o una
triada de profesionalidad o ahora javier
a le preguntó si tras ese escándalo en
la actualidad se puede despenalizar el
aborto en chile qué va a pasar con este
proyecto de ley que están nuevamente
realizando en el congreso
nosotros consideramos de que este
proyecto de ley es bastante importante
para para chile pero este no es el mismo
proyecto que se presenta en argentina
este un proyecto que solamente es
penaliza el aborto no la legalista qué
quiere decir esto que solamente lo quita
del código penal pero no lo tiene no
como una prestación porque porque en
chile todo aquellos proyectos de ley que
diga en relación con un cambio
presupuestario tiene que ser motivado
desde el ejecutivo y sabemos muy bien
que el presidente que actualmente
tenemos contrario a los derechos
sexuales ya los derechos reproductivos y
desafortunadamente no lo va a patrocinar
entonces nosotros esperamos que
esperamos que con la nueva constitución
y posteriormente con las elecciones que
tenemos a fin de año un nuevo presidente
pueda patrocinar este proyecto y
ampliarlo a una esfera desde un punto de
vista clínico y que en definitiva las
mujeres que quieran acceder a ello
puedan hacerlo de forma respetuosa y de
forma segura en los servicios atención
así de javier a gracias por su tiempo y
por estar aquí con nosotros en france 24
que tenga usted un feliz día y hasta
aquí 5 minutos con continúen con
nosotros para más noticias y más
actualidad internacional
[Música]